[Music]
what for Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
hey I'm mark barnard I love being here
man I actually had to wear the coat for
a reason today because the weather it's
nice to be out here where there's some
weather I just came from warm weather
and [ __ ] so it's nice to actually have
to wear the coat cuz [ __ ] it's chilly
here welcome ladies gentlemen we are
recording alive here at Kansas City
Comic Con put your hands together to the
folks at home know you are real
excellent
uh how's everybody's kind going so far I
just got in today and I've been having a
good time muse has been here a couple
days yeah good time when'd you get in ah
there we go
yesterday afternoon just just in time to
like have crazy barbecue sweats and and
I'm feeling it it took me some time to
recover today from last night's welcome
meets jiu-ge I mean we've known each
other for a while
I had at burn ends I had some pork ribs
I had some onion rings and pickles I
went to Arthur Bryant's is that a good
place I was told it was the [ __ ] so I
went cuz I'm the [ __ ] so yeah is so far
in town I know it's known for its
barbecue and stuff but the only cow
by-product I've enjoyed is a glass of
milk ah better for you I think they're
not barbecued at AWS like throw some
barbecue sauce in that they like [ __ ]
know what I we are now week two of thor
ragnarok yes yeah like being this is
Saturday or something like that
you've seen it more than I've seen two
three times how does it hold up insanely
well I mean there's that there's the
bits of it that are a little more plot
oriented than not but like it starts
really funny starts really exciting and
then it kind of slows down a little bit
for emotions and feelings and dying dads
and then [ __ ] Thor punches you know
the Hulk in the face a lot and
they try back up yeah I saw four
cosplayer today from Ragnarok yeah look
pretty with the short hair and ha see
it's easier now to cosplay thorn out
he's got a haircut yeah a lot of people
could jump on the Thor train you know
who heretofore weren't used to be only
Jay Mewes could play Thor now I got a
[ __ ] shot you know short Erik and it
made two hundred million dollars
domestically I think to this point
they've already passed the two hundred
yeah yeah because people like this movie
it's they deserve it they deserve to
make all the money it's so goddamn fun
and it still seems to be like the number
one choice yeah now number one choice
about to switch is that this week next
week the 17th so but you Justice League
is coming ladies and gentlemen those of
us who have been watching Superfriends
since we were children or a reading
about the Justice League of America in
comics since we were kids
finally get our chance to see a hero
team up on the screen and you know it's
it it's it's almost here the trailers
have started to shape up nicely
my favorite moment still and everything
I've seen is Batman telling flash saved
one person like that sounded very Batman
to me it sent a very super heroic the
idea of you know mentoring a young
fledgling flash to be like alright you
can't fight but just get in and save one
person he's like Ben why he's like then
you'll know what to do and I didn't
write the script I'm not a genius
but I suspect he'll save more than one
person I like where the story is going
man I like that Batman and flash like
Schindler's List I could have saved one
more these cuff links well that's what
Warner Brothers marketing wants people
to think of when they think of Justice
League just like in the tradition of
Schindler's List
he loves his League one person at a time
I'm looking forward to it and I you know
I thought you know did not exhaust all
my look I'll watch any [ __ ] comic
book movie but as a wonderful as Thor
was and whatnot it was not like I'm done
for a while I'm more than happy to go
see Justice League and it looks like
thanks to Mark Bernardin's
tendrils in the business his bona fides
not mine I literally asked Jordan who is
Jason's wife who runs our company's
Monaco like Warner Brothers has asked me
to do things from time to time and I go
host screenings or whatever or do press
they asked me I don't know how it got
this far I know how I interviewed denne
denne vill knew in San Diego at San
Diego comic-con and we got along super
grey and I was able to deep dive and
Blom about his entire [ __ ] career and
stuff made him feel good and stuff so
when that Bladerunner picture was coming
out Warner Brothers is like oh we're
having a press screening you know like
for the junket we need a moderator for
the screening like it's gonna be Denny
and Ryan Gosling and the rest of the
cast
Harrison Ford does Kevin want to go host
the the Q&F ice [ __ ] yeah are you
kidding me for the selfie with Harrison
Ford alone like that be worth the trip
and [ __ ] but to like sit there and blow
Gosling and what Knox I think he's
really [ __ ] legit funny I know he's a
really good actor and [ __ ] but like he
should do a lot more comedy I was gonna
try to convince him to do mine but in
any event I was like I'm more than happy
to do it and then I guess somebody
somewhere down the line was like what no
and I was so excited cuz I was like oh
my god I'm gonna hang out with the big
leaguers and [ __ ] like that and I
invited my kid I rarely do that I'm like
hey kiddo they asked your father to
moderate the panel after the blamers
she's like he's Ryan Gosling gonna be
there I said yeah she's like I'm going
so I literally had to like sit my kid
down and be like you're your father has
no juice whatsoever no Warner Brothers
showed me the door on this [ __ ]
screening so I asked Jordan I said all
right man like I know they felt bad
about getting me excited and then being
like oh we're not gonna use a moderator
I said so I'm sure we can work that to
our advantage
see if they'll let us see Justice League
a little bit early shut down
nothing mark on the other hand has
access where'd you get your JLA or
Justice League access from from old
publicists to owe me favors ultimately
is where it comes down to you know mark
for those that don't follow closely
enough not only is he a writer of fine
fictions and
comic books what's your comic book
that's out right now they can buy the
genius comic book genius cartel on
stands now who there's one dude who look
really lovely SHhhh bye woo top cow
image only if I sell one comic book feel
that much better everything aside from
being a writer of Fine fictions marc has
worked in the world of journalism and
he's edited at Entertainment Weekly and
at Hollywood Reporter and at playboy and
at Los Angeles Times was last job yet
calendar section in Los Angeles Times
when you're doing the film section
that's everything man everything that
town is all about movies so like you've
got you you you are access Lord you're
the person that everybody has to kind of
come through and see and bend a knee and
you get to see everything early and
stuff he gave it up because he wants to
be a writer more than he wants to be
that guy but that being said more thank
God you know people who'll get us into
[ __ ] movies early yeah I mean so I
reached that not not that early because
people have seen it already
yeah there's word coming out we snuck it
under the wire so we're gonna see it on
Wednesday alright so we see a Wednesday
it comes out on Friday yeah or Thursday
night basically we see a 24-hour channel
we you got sweet access all that [ __ ]
juice man oh my god is from the
concentrate this is tell you're beating
me hands down
I had no access other than like we can
go on Friday I didn't even know about
the Thursday night [ __ ] screenings
but I look forward to it I can't wait
and then you know good or bad whatever I
look I look forward to being good but
good bad or indifferent if wait a few
minutes and then last Jedi is gonna
happen all over our face neck and chest
so I can't [ __ ] wait and that would
probably be a good way to segue right to
the news because I imagine the top news
story has something to do with Star Wars
yeah there's a there's a couple of
[ __ ] things about stores we can talk
about they just they they just launched
all the Star Wars news at once a lot of
people theorize it's because the
projections came out with I don't follow
stock so I don't speak that language so
I'm not gonna pretend to know what it's
about but I guess Disney stock more or
less was down yeah once again having
everything to do with broadcast with the
SPN for some reason is waiting them the
[ __ ] down
Espeon used to elevate them and now like
it disney's trying to figure out what to
do about it because it keeps bringing
their stock down or whatever right so
what a shareholders call the head of
Disney just basically had to convince
people not to sell their Disney stock by
saying no you guys we swear it's gonna
be Star Wars forever is that so that's
what it is like you're on a phone call
with shareholders yeah and I guess
majority shareholders right and so the
press gets to listen in and separate
that out that's how that works I have no
[ __ ] idea that's that's pretty
interesting
I just learned some [ __ ] two years ago I
think that's when they announced that
they were making another Indiana Jones
movie like in a shareholder call they
said oh yes Bill Bergen and and Ford are
coming back for Indiana Jones which
whatever happened to that but I don't
know that's true so the idea is our
stocks going down but don't [ __ ]
abandon us as you know we're Disney
number one will be we you know as as
with cancer we'll be with you always you
know so we're not going anywhere but
like hey not for nothing but we are
doing this this and this and that makes
people on the phone go oh [ __ ] a lot of
laughs right fly unzipping like look you
guys don't be afraid we have a
prodigious [ __ ] with Disney it's okay
yeah that was just the tip here's the
rest but yes so they signed a ryan
johnson to make a new trilogy any Star
Wars trilogy three films that he'll
write in direct Rian Johnson director of
looper crap and now the director of the
last Jedi which so far every TV spot and
trailer I've seen in the last month in a
way that you know I was always ready to
see this I'm in the bag for all this
[ __ ] what do I what else do I got going
on in life I love going to the movies
and stuff and I love seeing Star Wars
movies since I was a kid
I hope to see him until the day I die
and I hope that day is a long time from
now but even if it's [ __ ] tomorrow I
can't complain I've seen a lot of
[ __ ] Star Wars movies now they're
bringing him out at a much faster rate
and whatnot so I was always in the bag
for this stuff that being said first
trailer for the last Jedi was a guy
right on I'll see ya you know she moved
to rock this looks cool but when they
got into all the trailers like the
second trailer and all the TV spots have
been releasing this month this this
looks pretty [ __ ] wonderful I mean
just the shot of Luke walking into the
Malia Falcon and my nipples just got
hard
yes Oh like this so I didn't know I
wanted this bad but the [ __ ] bring it
it's true it's everything and then you
realize like whoa and and I I don't know
if we'll get that now unless they did it
in this movie as well we got to see Han
Solo and Chewie both re-enter the
cockpit we've now seen the solo shot of
Luke Skywalker reenter the cockpit I
wonder if there is a Princess Leia
moment but if not we know why not
what an amazing it's weird you didn't
realize how much you wanted to see that
moment and has everything to do with the
performance and man we saw it for like
what three seconds and in a trailer but
marks turning on the lights and looking
around like just grabs you right here in
the heart it's it's it's the wonder of
wait you know like I remember feeling
that way at the end of Creed or even at
the [ __ ] beginning of Creed like the
minute you realize that Oh Stallone has
been involved with this thing for 40
years and just seeing him back in the
ring seeing him be Stallone seeing him
be be [ __ ] Balboa seeing him walk up
those steps again you don't get that
without 40 years of history you don't
get the chills of Luke Skywalker back in
the fountain without 40 years I've just
we've been living with this dreaming
this and see that's what I gotta aim for
you know we're making a sequel to Jay
and Silent Bob strike back call Jay and
Sam Bob reboot and you know it's the
same [ __ ] movie all over its they
find out that Hollywood's doing a reboot
of the old Bluntman and chronic movies
that go back to Hollywood to stop it
again that being said what would be my
equivalent moment what is the Rocky
going up the steps where Luke Skywalker
walking into the it is hot so it's the
the street light going on over the quick
stop like him Jane Senna Bob returned to
the quick stop and there's the wall that
they leaned against and the light goes
on we're home
I guess them in front of the wall is
we're home that's true
I got to figure that out because that's
what's gonna sell the movie that being
said we're not [ __ ] story so it's not
gonna sound that much
alright so Rian Johnson the lad who's in
charge of looper who is now in charge of
starwars when they dropped Colin
Trevorrow or whether he walked or
whatever when that cat left the third
Star Wars movie we talked about Jesus I
mean everyone seems to love ryan's
version so much
they went to JJ that's great because JJ
kicked it off force awakens but I wonder
why they skipped Bryan then we found out
why they skip Bryan because they sent
Ryan down they're like you have your own
trilogy just for you buddy
do whatever you want and [ __ ] the
Skywalker's tell a different story man a
trilogy of Jar Jar movies anything you
want what do you think he's gonna do
I've seen a lot of people theorizing on
Twitter they put up Knights of the Old
Republic I mean I mean going back feels
not to say it feels easier but because
you get to play with that history but
you it has built-in residence but I
don't know man like I think for him the
fertile ground is going forward going
forward yeah I think well you know
they've talked about like young Ben
Kenobi movie so maybe I thought maybe
they would do like you know we never
really saw like the deep cut Clone Wars
as much as we did on the show the Clone
Wars so there's plenty story they could
tell well what's the character's name
Osaka Osaka - ahsoka tano
they're like maybe maybe it's there
maybe you bring in that character into
the world but whatever the cat's gonna
do man it's like that's I remember you
know they announced long time ago George
Lucas announced there are nine of these
movies and we saw three and then years
later we saw another three where we were
like please take him away and then now
we're in the middle of seeing what I was
told from childhood was the last three
right so you know JJ's presumably would
be last but you know most people are
like do you really think they bought
Star Wars just to stop at nine like
you're gonna see [ __ ] Star Wars 28
and [ __ ] like that I hope by the time I
die I live that long and stuff but I
guess you could keep going there's no
reason not to and if you were if it is
the ongoing Star Wars saga and it is a
trilogy maybe he is heading into the
future I mean it could be it could be
you get you know 20 years from now that
john boyega's like old finn like
came back on a stormtrooper costume and
the lights go on above it and the music
plays and there's always just building
nostalgia building reasons to be
nostalgic that's what it is right it's
just basically they're like look at this
[ __ ] don't you miss being a child give
us your money you man and we'll make you
a child woman give us your money we'll
make you a girl we're the Fountain of
[ __ ] youth Disney basically yeah what
else did they announce they announce
that he's got a trilogy of his own but
didn't they and also announced something
else about like a Star Wars yeah because
they're also talking about the app the
Disney we're making you buy our stuff
piecemeal for those that don't follow
this story closely enough we all know
worship at the altar of Netflix it's
changed all our lives and as much as we
have no lives anymore we just sit there
in deep dive on programs CBS recently
launched their own app and they did so
very successfully by going hey do you
like Star Trek was the only [ __ ]
place you'll ever get it so buy our app
and it's worked out very well so the
idea as all these companies are now
launching their own app channels is
everybody wants a driver on the channel
something that's gonna make people want
to join in it's not enough to be like
hey we got every [ __ ] old Star Wars
movie in every Marvel movie here what's
driving it what's the future what's the
present what makes me would you know
make sure it's it's a sweeter offer than
that so just the way that Star Trek was
CB the CBS the CBS app all-access app
whatever they call it
that was their driver yeah it sounds
like the Disney app which they still
haven't named yet I mean there's a
version of it that exists in the UK in
the UK Disney go or something like that
but this is it's all of the Disney
classic library all of the Marvel
Library and all of Star Wars as well yep
and then a new live-action Star Wars
show they announced a new as yet
untitled Marvel show live-action over it
and then a Monsters Inc TV show those
are gonna be their drivers so I get it
so the - you got your hero show you got
your Star Wars show so you got both ends
of fandom there and then you got your
kiddie cartoon show yeah to keep them
like a man well I got a [ __ ] through
year-old they don't give a [ __ ] about
marvel well show him the monsters thanks
TV
that makes sense and they've been talks
for years about a live-action Star Wars
show like there's apparently somewhere
at Lucasfilm and the ranch there's a
closet full of scripts that had been
written for the live-action 50 or 60
scripts that Lucas himself was like
we're gonna make a show
there's our sure if I can make a show
when he put all this stuff in the closet
I'm gonna spend millions of dollars and
it's fine is that your Lucas that's as
close to Lucas as I get I mean I got too
much natural bass in this voice that's I
drew him he's Jimmy D sounds like Kermit
I made Star Wars so the TV shot saw
somebody on Twitter made me chuckle they
were like you know cuz I was like I
think this is great and then somebody
about Ryan getting a new trilogy and
somebody was like hey you [ __ ] thing
everything's great
so that don't matter but be there like
don't this like with a movie a TV show
doesn't just feel like you know
spreading it thin like they did with
Planet of the Apes back in the 70s and I
was like that's where you had to reach
to like Planet of the Apes I don't think
it is spreading it too thin I think you
got some big concepts like Star Wars and
like Marvel people will watch any
permutation of it and they have a deep
bench in the case of Marvel oh my god so
many characters in IP that maybe
wouldn't make sense for like a network
TV show but would make sense as a driver
for that app yeah and there's so much
talent out there who would kill killed
like firstborns of their own other
peoples do but first Born's would just
go to get to write a Star Wars show or
to get to write a Marvel show would you
[ __ ] yeah I don't like my firstborn
she's a teenager
I don't know I some part of me just
wants to enjoy some of this [ __ ] like I
I know because of what I've done for a
living it gets you into a place where
you can do these things and whatnot and
I you know people ask me why don't you
want to make a superhero movie but how
I'm not really number one it seems hard
and long and you know I don't do
anything hard or long I'm not [ __ ]
one-minute man at best and stuff so the
idea of putting all that into it like I
don't know that's for better people than
me
and at the same time I also just enjoy
being an audience member for that the
same way like I go to like a courtroom
drama and I love courtroom drama but
I've never thought about making one
myself and I don't sit there and go like
I should [ __ ] do that I can go to any
superhero movie and never sit there and
go like well this is what I would do
better because most of the time like I
would never have done anything nearly as
[ __ ] good I stand there still I'm a
guy who sees beyond the curtain knows
how this shit's done and still I'll
watch a movie slack-jawed and be like
how'd they make him fly that's so [ __ ]
up and I know exactly I like mega fun
they show you all the behind the scenes
footage now is watching Saban the scenes
footage Justice League [ __ ] and you see
Affleck without the cape on Batman like
pretty Cape list the whole movie while
they're shooting and then they'll show
cyborg and he's just wearing the pajamas
with the green lights on and [ __ ] like
that but like you realize Batman's K+
because they're just gonna make the Cape
because nobody likes ID rapey hanging
cape anymore and they're like I will
spend an extra hundred thousand dollars
to bring the Cape to life and stuff so
they show all these shots of him doing
things and it's weird because it's like
Batman without a cape and then they show
you the finished footage you know like
oh even the capes [ __ ] fake at this
point which makes sense is something
like Doctor Strange where the cape is
like Groot a character or something like
that but in Batman's case it's just like
look how [ __ ] wicked we can make it
look I mean that's the one thing I give
props to for the CGI cape is you can now
get as close as possible to a panel from
a comic book you can replicate something
that only in two dimensions with pencil
owning could people heretofore really do
that massive unrealistic spread same way
like now with CG like remember when Todd
McFarlane first put spider-man's knees
up to his ears and you were like oh my
god why doesn't everybody do this and
then they're like because this is an
inhuman position no human being could do
this and then you're like yeah but he's
[ __ ] spider-man he's kind of inhuman
himself and then suddenly in the CG
world they can match that like I watched
rewatch Civil War again and my god like
they have him doing [ __ ] look straight
out the comics it's it's amazing so hats
off to the see what I'm waiting for is
the the the behind the scenes clip of
Justice League that shows Superman with
the porn mustache
yes
for those not following that story very
closely they had to go back and do
reshoots for Justice League Joss Whedon
was in charge of those so we're getting
movies directed by mostly Zack Snyder a
little bit by Joss Whedon and when they
went back what's his name henry cavill
was shooting mission impossible 19 or
whatever the [ __ ] for Paramount and
oddly enough his character has a
pornstar moustache one of those like
smashes the pushy Tom Selleck beasted
clone his upper lip very much a Tom
Selleck
so you know they he's he's on he belongs
to paramount contractually because he
finished Justice League they were done
with him and stuff and he went on to his
next movie which presumably was this and
Warner Brothers reached out to Paramount
to be like hey we need Henry for
reshoots can we have him and you they
were like I guess you know they're they
said yes but then they got like funny
shitty they were like you can have him
but he's got to keep his mustache and
there were Warner Brothers like what the
[ __ ] Superman don't wear a mustache and
they're like well then you're gonna have
to CG out his mustache forever shot like
do you know what that's gonna cost like
a man don't matter
contractually he belongs to us [ __ ] you
it's your mustache ride you know so so
Warner Bros is like we got to do this we
got to shoot it this is the window [ __ ]
it alright bring Henry in and they shot
all of that footage with Henry as
Superman wearing that [ __ ] goofy
mustache that he has in Mission
Impossible and then they spent upwards
of got to be 200 maybe quarter of a
million dollars easy to remove and I you
know what do we know we're not insiders
but I do know what CG cost particularly
really good CG particularly CG for a
main character in a movie that was
coming out in ten [ __ ] minutes so
they didn't have all the time in the
world that bill was high they went in
and digitally shaved off Henry Capitals
mustache in every scene as Superman now
that sounds like it's [ __ ] you know I
guess that makes sense it sounds easy
but the problem is you're taking off a
layer and you have to replace a layer
which means that a digital artist had to
draw his entire upper lip for most of
those shots
you see his face where the mustache
would be an early word apparently as
most people that are seeing Justice
League just keep staring at [ __ ] but
man's lip and the best part is you know
how much like a fake mustache to put on
a bald lip would cost like 70 bucks but
like they even if they did a new one
every [ __ ] day paramount like we
could each a fine we could just glue it
on no even if they were like we're gonna
construct his fake moustache from the
finest mole hairs you know of dead
Egyptian moles from the Mesopotamia or
something like that it still wouldn't
cost as much as like you know we took
that one out we took that one out we
took that one out every time you see him
in the movie not every time we don't
know that for a fact true but enough
times but enough times you're gonna
spend a lot of time going ok that was
they shot that during production they
shot that during Mission Impossible
because you're gonna see a weird wobbly
lip I would imagine right I mean no
matter how good you are as a CG artist
that's that's that's tough and that's
the footage I want to see I want to see
if I can porn star Superman they should
put that on a blu-ray now the mustache
cut you know how Logan did a black and
white version like here's the version
where cavils mustache is not taken out
this is what Superman would look like if
he was played by magnum p.i is
everything is an innuendo suddenly all
right so back to the TV show the Star
Wars TV show I'm so down with this yeah
if you're number one because I don't
have to make it so great it's on
somebody else
you say that now yeah would you like to
direct an episode I'm like [ __ ] you I
always want to have r2d2 call c-3po [ __ ]
smoker like thank you moving on um so a
Marvel show then in hints at what it
could do now good to own Marvel cuz you
can just throw that word out at any time
you want if people like go [ __ ]
yourselves you like a little marvel
they're like woo you have my attention
yet what do you need it's also doubly
interesting because Moon Knight I'm
hoping from Moon Moon I'd be pretty
amazing you know what I'm saying it
should be a beefy show like I agents of
shield I know has its audience and stuff
and I respect the show but like if
you're gonna drive people to your app
and
make them pay more money or not as
they're saying not as much as Netflix
they've said like we're not gonna be
nearly as but how much does Netflix now
yeah $15.99 right what is it oh that's a
[ __ ] bargain man I spend more time
with Netflix than my family like 1099
it's a [ __ ] that's what they're
saying there's would be less than that
if they're saying substantially less
you're talking what $5.99 I can't
imagine a do $5.99 you disguise its
money leaving on the table like you'll
if you had been a Disney they could
leave money on the table for a while
knowing they'll get all that cheddar
later on it's a mouse he knows how to
get the cheese if you're doing that if
you got to drive people they buy yet one
more app Channel moon night would be I'm
not putting this out there in the world
oh my god I'd fun look don't get my
money anyway but I'd buy you a
subscription and all everybody
subscriptions they're like it's moon
night oh my god we're very good to see
it if it's Marvel's Batman finally done
right
my money's on bleed oh oh I think I
think you could do a blade TV show and
very inexpensively - or you can spend
like agents of shield money or flash
money and still make a pretty
good-looking show yeah and vampires and
vampires yeah good call I like your
version better than mine that's alright
yours is good too alright so that's all
the news that they had not quite there
was there's also rumblings that the the
the pencils are still not down yet the
ink is not yet dry but Disney is in
talks with Marvel I'm sorry with Fox for
a merger of some sort this is a big
story came out last week and one of the
rare wonderful stories in Hollywood that
has nothing to do with sexual misconduct
lately it is a story about how Marvel
Mart Disney and Fox we're talking about
Fox unloading all of their IP their
movie stuff their TV stuff Fox you know
wanting to predominantly stick with what
their identity is a news network at the
spread news and sports I think is only
thing it was in sports so they were like
well maybe we're done with the movies
you know and movies ain't that
fashionable anymore maybe you know we'd
like to get rid of this
Disney was like we'll [ __ ] buy all
your trash because like we believed in
the IP you're kidding me like you know
we number one our company was founded on
intellectual property the [ __ ] mouse
and all his friends and [ __ ] and they
have been able to regrow and change
their business and altar for the tastes
of the modern audience every step of the
way at one point Disney bought Miramax
and then they sold Miramax years later
and they bought Marvel and then they
bought Star Wars or vice versa and now
they're in the business of potentially
buying back Marvel assets that were
never gonna be open to them we know how
shitty Fox was being about the whole
thing
there was never gonna be any sort of
Sony come-to-jesus let us use Spider Man
conversation whatsoever Fox is like [ __ ]
you we even make an x-men movie since
you guys [ __ ] we're just dreaming
about doing Ironman and we've been doing
it right we don't need your [ __ ] help
and guess what we just did Deadpool and
Logan those [ __ ] like crack the earth
wide open and [ __ ] we have a new space
we're in go [ __ ] yourselves you know and
they're like and we're keeping the
Fantastic Four because we're [ __ ] like
that but now that gives Disney a chance
to like buy back the Marvel family so
you get not just the Fantastic Four but
the entire x-men universe which means
you can the Marvel Studios it contains
all the characters that you could
possibly have for those don't follow
this thing very closely years ago
Stanley went out to Hollywood and sold
off a bunch of the popular Marvel
characters to different movie deals
movie studios and producers the problem
is the they were in perpetuity deals so
as long as people were making new
versions of those characters and movies
the people who bought the rights or
licensed the rights held the rights so
you know Marvel wouldn't get it back
this is exciting because it means they'd
get all their characters back under one
roof but it's also exciting for like
every other implication it has to it
like Disney would own the Simpsons
suddenly they would they would own all
of effects that own all the Fox
Broadcasting they would own Fargo and
the strain and the Simpsons and all that
stuff it's super exciting and there's
also a little bit that's kind of a
little frightening why about it because
it's all becoming one because world one
universe one network when you get the
kind of giant conglomerate that can
suddenly start to set prices and fees
and how much people get paid and all of
the shittiness that you know about like
there's a reason why you can't but
antitrust and stuff and you can't also
be a this an event and of this if you
control too much of the process then you
begin to sort of ice up competition and
competition is what makes it good
competition is what makes the the sort
of little lifeblood of the industry and
if this giant megalithic corporation
suddenly is setting the terms there's a
little bit of like I'm afraid of what'll
happen let's and let's take a moment to
just recognize the fact that 20th
Century Fox is like we want out of the
movie business yeah well that's like
much for us who is a Darryl F zanuck who
created that company yeah back in the
day and it's all predicated on we're
making motion pictures and now these
cats are just like [ __ ] motion pictures
get Rudy Disney man that's crazy never
did you think you'd see it in this
lifetime but they don't have like you
know look they've had classic movies
over the years but it's three of their
biggest movies of all time with the Star
Wars movies yeah once Star Wars went to
Disney
maybe that's what started opening up the
talks that x-men and you got plenty of
the apes and that's about it that's
right they still find the Apes as well
yeah Wow
well so pencils are not down meaning
they're still in discussions I think the
idea was somebody floated that rumor or
floated the fact that it was there was
discussions to see if it would affect
the stock price and it did positively
affect the 20th Century Fox stock price
they would still need to make their deal
and the government we're suing to prove
it because a deal of this merger of this
size requires federal approval but
there's a world in which phase 5 of the
Marvel of the MCU involves the x-men oh
that's [ __ ] crazy
could you imagine one more reason to
stay when life is its most bleak I just
think about like now I want to see black
panther and then like now I want to see
an Avengers infinity war which I always
want to call Infinity Gauntlet but I
guess that's not an infinity war all
right is that all the news out of Disney
that is all the news out of Disney the
next bit of news comes out of Warner
Brothers well I guess it's a little bit
of Disney Warner Brothers ok Brian
Michael Bendis who had
this is comic book new this is
comic-book news Brian Michael Bendis
Marvel cover pun yeah he had been in in
a very real way the the chief architect
of Marvel's creative Renaissance well no
one could argue that if there was a
Mount Rushmore of Marvel creators yeah
Bendis would have to be on it by this
point I mean he he almost
single-handedly saved Marvel Comics in a
real way with the ultimate universe or
the ultimate universe all this is I work
on went on Marvel nights with daredevil
I mean with the ultimate spider-man like
he so much of what Marvel became was
because of him and even just as a talent
recruiter as a dude who had done indie
comics who got brought in could be the
shepherd for people like Jonathan
Hickman infraction and Jason Aaron and
guys like that's a guys come on board
like they're treating us well we get to
play with the big toys we get to have
fun again and and for him to get wooed
across the aisle to DC is massive has
there been any inside news on that since
I remember broke the other day it was on
Twitter and whatnot but as anybody has
there been the big interview where he's
like yeah they just [ __ ] backed up
the mark or was he like look how many
times can I tell him a Marvel story I've
done it now history he spoke to the New
York Times and I think it was a little
bit of like not that I've done all I
could do at Marvel because and they've
been very good to me it's not there's no
ill will at all but just there's a whole
box of toys on the other side of the
road like why not get to play with that
and I'm assuming that DC just unloaded
the money truck because that's a big
money truck you got on low how does this
all right so it's if it's positive for
DC we'll see they get a new creative
input and whatnot and then a fan
favorite somebody is gonna be able to
put asses and sees his people like I
just want to see what he'll do with X Y
or Z Batman just like whatever what does
this mean for Marvel though to lose
somebody who seems like a big part of
their spine for the last like that feels
like 15 20 years yeah I mean I think
this they maybe 10 15 years this is what
sports teams like to call a rebuilding
phase where they've lost their star
player like and and market share will
show that no matter what events Marvel
kind of launches it's still diminishing
returns and it's time for them to kind
of rebuild and go back into the into
both their bench and to recruit some new
voices to do that thing that Bendis did
10 years ago which was find me these
guys who write really well find me these
guys who were super
Get Smart find me the next wave of
Marvel creators and I think that's where
they are and and they'd also disbanded
like Marvel had this creative committee
I think yeah that consulted on all the
Marvel movies for a stretch and Ben this
was the sort of chief person on that
list but fraction and make men and all
those guys and Brubaker clearly because
I'd say you get Winter Soldier but they
had disbanded that and so his farvel
Studios I think despair yeah yeah I
think and I think some of that was also
James Gunn was like hey guys I got this
like I can figure out guardians by
myself I don't need is that right I
never heard that really yeah I think he
was like yeah I don't see the point of
this it's we're building it out of whole
cloth it has no real connections at this
point to them all the universe I got it
I'm good and then they were like well
why don't we need them then if we all
got it and we're good but there's a
world in which you know Jeff Jones is
the busiest person at DC maybe he needs
another dude to help him Shepherd the
movie and TV stuff and who's been in
those rooms and have those conversations
with studio execs what DC character do
you most want to see Bendis to swing it
I don't know like I there's a world in
which they absolutely give him Superman
because of course we got you know we got
a sluggard we're not gonna put him on
our best book but there's also like I'd
love to see him do it as a Tanner book
like I'd love to see him just find some
character that isn't getting love that
kind of meshes with his sensibilities is
like a street level writer like even
though there's magic and stuff it's
still the dark of Gotham like let him
let him loose on Nightwing let him loose
on Suicide Squad I would be - Suicide
Squad remember no heartbeat I think the
idea of Superman is interesting yeah
I've never think of that but you're
right why not put him on like your big
book yeah where your big character
that's like honestly you hear a lot of
writers say it one of the tougher
characters to write like let's see what
like he unders could do with the Haysom
with Superman yeah interesting alright
that's good news for for Brian good news
for comics particularly DC but we'll see
what it means for Marvel going down the
road yeah it just feels like they lost
like they're besties yeah I mean Jason
Aaron is still over there doing some
pretty strong work but there's there's
there's not a lot of other people in
that bullpen um what else we got
there's gonna be a new Twilight Zone TV
show did you hear about this is exciting
because it's Jordan Peele correct it's
Jordan Peele dete were you guys Twilight
Zone fans every incarnation I've loved
The Twilight Zone
I mean did the Rod Serling version that
show is from my money the greatest
achievement in the history of television
why because he wrote half of them
himself every episode there's no
continuing characters there's no
continuing story every episode is
starting from scratch and to come up
with a hundred and seventy-five episodes
of that most of which are really good
without being able to lean back on
anything it's true you don't have like
you know this guy's our goal like you
got nobody with a catchphrase man
because like the next week it's a
different episode next week different
the anthology doesn't allow itself for
the easy sell totally like you are you
are creating a new world every 30
minutes and you're doing that on a
ridiculous schedule like they did 40
episodes a year back in the day and he
wrote half of them himself it's it's
Emma's in a mall and was in a mall like
it's ungodly the level of achievement
that is so - want to take another whack
at it like yeah I get it it's a crown
jewel of CBS but that is it that is a
tough [ __ ] bill real quick before we
move on to the present version of it
like also didn't he [ __ ] work on
playing the ape sterling yeah he reacted
the first novel he took Goulet's book
and he wrote the script yeah and change
the ending like they did that ending is
his with the Statue of Liberty yeah are
you shedding man the original book ends
in a space capsule with monkeys looking
down on earth like they've launched
themselves into space and I think they
see like Taylor ship pass by or
something like that really yeah it's a
monkeys in space ending which one of
those you know as you do but wait so so
similarly the one with the Statue of
Liberty yeah what a genius
all right so yes tall a tall order but
big shoes to fill but isn't I mean we
all love to get out mm-hmm didn't he
just get a job with Jay Jay doing some
sort of anthem anthem
Jordan seems to be in the like I've been
waiting long enough I'm about to
assemble my own Avengers and he's
setting up stuff all over town like he's
not gonna run the twilight zone show
Marco Ramirez who did the first season
of daredevil would run Twilight Zone for
him cool but it it lends itself to the
things that Jordan is good at which is
looking at-at genre because comedy
qualifies as genre and finding the ways
to talk about current events you know
and also working short form and working
short form like if it's gonna be an
ontology like it used to be science
fiction is all about the looking at us
now and painting in a different way and
finding the the weird nuggets of
humanity and writing them large and
making it so that you don't quite
recognize that this episode is about
McCarthyism and this episode is about
this and this is about race and this is
about gender and class and all of that
stuff that's what the Twilight Zone was
but it was a sort of seminar and that
was when the audience wasn't as Swift
you know what I'm saying like they were
still it was new it's not like they were
done but then seen tropes for 4050 years
like now it's tough to put anything in
front of an audience where they can't
see something like all [ __ ] that guy
did it and she's the villain and this is
gonna happen like they could figure it
out all pretty easy back then they this
was a guy who is exposing so much new on
a regular basis you know people were
like wow what a magic trick now it's a
lot tougher to pull off that magic trick
a we know the formula of a Twilight Zone
or an anthology show whether it be a
tales from the dark side or basic
stories or there is a dark side tells
him the dark side outer limits which one
our limits okay there you go going
old-school and stuff but like now so we
all know the formula and whatnot so just
when you think okay hey that had its
time and sci-fi short stories with
zingers at the end with M night twists
will always have a place in our hearts
but they don't really make that anymore
any time they tried to redo the Twilight
Zone the last couple seasons and go away
black mirror inarguably has taken the
mantle of The Twilight Zone into the
21st century so in terms of a high if
you've never seen black mirror on that
flix spend the time it is worth it it is
some of the most amazing storytelling
some of the most amazing writing
currently working in production anywhere
the they won an Emmy for an episode
called San Junipero I wouldn't recommend
starting with that episode because it's
misleading and as much as it's a very
happy story all of the black mirror
stories make you feel terrible about
being a human being first you sit there
judging others and then you realize it's
about you and you're like oh my god I
suck too so Sanji de perro is one of the
episodes of black mirror that is just
completely different so don't start with
that one because then you'll be like wow
what a this shows full of hope and then
you'll realize it's hopelessness yeah
let's start with the first one after
that Oh must be live Pig oh [ __ ]
yes that was my first experience with it
was and spoilers this isn't well this
doesn't spoil it because this is right
right in the log line of the episode
this will tell you whether or not you
want to try black mirror and after he
told me this I did which means I'm as
[ __ ] up as he is the it begins very
urgently with disappearance of someone
related to the Royals or something like
princess and the Prime Minister of
England is being asked in order to save
the princess's life to [ __ ] a pig live
on television like added by a certain
hour and if that don't make you wanna
watch I you're a way better person than
me man cuz it was sold to me about this
is about like how the Prime Minister has
to [ __ ] pay and I'm like what what
wait what no I just watch it just watch
it and it's pretty [ __ ] fast and
every aspect of it is fascinating and it
almost plays but the beauty of black
mirror is it mirrors our culture so
[ __ ] closely you can see this
happening like you can be like oh my god
this is what it would be like it's not
even a far stretch of the imagination
anymore so it is it's fully worth taking
the the black mirror trip
that being said that just makes a new
Twilight Zone even harder yeah a nice to
do it for CBS
that's right man cuz on Netflix you
could curse and you
do a bunch of stuff that on CBS they're
gonna have to play it straight according
to network rule yeah oh if anyone could
do it he can Jordan Ken yeah I think so
he's having a run man good for him all
right so that's hot I look forward to
that did you ever read the boys the
Garth Ennis tennis is that happening
that is happening is it happening with
Seth yes I knew it he'd four years when
we're back we're mega Zack and Miri Make
a Porno he's like I ever read the boys I
[ __ ] love it and so he'd been talking
about doing it back then that was before
he was Seth Rogen and him and Evan I
would imagine he's doing it with Evan
that's fantastic oh yeah I knew this was
gonna happen
Amazon gave it a full season order
really yes now amaz so he spread his
[ __ ] around on Hulu he's got that future
man about his show about to happen yeah
which is kind of like their take on The
Last Starfighter and now you're saying
that Amazon they're gonna be doing the
boys and then the preacher still
creatures over at AMC the preacher is
still the preaching on AMC good for him
with anything about it just that's it
it's got a home and they're doing it
yeah I mean a little bit of [ __ ]
history about it but I don't think he's
gonna run the show there's gonna run the
show blah blah somebody else O'Hara
Kripke who did a supernatural right he's
gonna run this show for them but it's a
huge deal and I remember when it was it
was a wild storm booked for like eight
issues I think and then did anybody read
does it me remember the history of it
white jumped to dynamite know what
happened because I think they put like
an anal sex joke in the book like I
think it was scar tennis it's garth on
doesn't make sense and Paul Levitz read
it and and vetoed it but then they
published it anyway like under his nose
or down his back yeah and so it went out
and he was like [ __ ] we're never
doing in otherwise it was selling 40 50
thousand copies a month and and Paul
Levitz was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you [ __ ]
the boys you're done Wow yeah and so
they jumped at dynamite and then he went
for another like three or four years and
still selling a bunch of issues but yeah
and now it's TV show and now it's a TV
show but it was creator-owned when it
was at DC right I mean there's a
Wildstorm books and there were some
creator-owned
to it but there was always the we
reserve the right to bounce whatever you
want to bounce and now they got no
contact with and now yeah so sorry DC I
I worked with Seth on Zack you Miri Make
a Porno and not only was it just a blast
to work with him and see him his talent
his [ __ ] immense he was the guy that
turned me into a STONER
so if you're depending on where you are
on that side of the equation some people
I liked you earlier better [ __ ]
then blame [ __ ] Seth Rogen but if
you're like [ __ ] I love that walrus
movie then blame Seth Rogen but he is
he's doing it right you know with it
with he's had a lot of success and with
that success
he just keeps making [ __ ] he's always
wanted to see I talked to him at San
Diego on IMDB recently interviewed him
that looked like I was jerking him off
that's me doing a microphone between him
and me and him and he said he's just
like his mantra is like if we don't do
it somebody else is gonna [ __ ] it up and
I like that it's kind of very offensive
defensive thing we're like we want to do
this because we know if it's gonna get
done eventually and when it gets done
it's definitely not gonna be done right
so that's why we're pushing it forward
and we want to do it it's a smart play
it's been working out yeah he's the king
of [ __ ] comic-book media at this
point and he that's the other thing
this is dude who could generate for
himself obviously write scripts all the
time and stuff but this is the stuff
that he enjoys and he's like this should
be someplace else this should be on TV
that's true comic book fan right there
pretty hard it's using the little
wattage to make stuff happen and make it
happen right yeah you know like his his
job on this will not be to run the show
I think he and evident gonna direct the
pilot but it will be to stand between
Amazon and his showrunner and deflect
like they want you to change this Seth
can you make them I got this don't worry
about it
like that's that's when a Seth will you
make your your staff change this I take
it that - no I mean on Castle Rock that
was JJ's job JJ's job was to just like
alright what do you not want to do I
will I will make it go away I will get
you the cash you want I will convince
them to spend the money and then I will
be the buffer between you and the
network letting you do what you do and
that's that's
a good place to be that's how you get
good [ __ ] well us we got in the news we
got one last bit about there making a
Shazam movie yes they are and they cast
zactly Zach Levi is shocked himself
chuck is bringing it to play well what I
used to call Captain Marvel but I guess
they're now calling Shazam because yeah
Marvel's like [ __ ] you we own Captain
Marvel so Shazam he is now yeah now
who's playing the boy do you know this
kid from the Disney Channel named Asher
Angel which sounds totally made up but
whatever Jamal I mean it's no fin
wolfhard
but still that name really sounds
made-up like by a porn star - yeah but
so yeah he's gonna be playing young
Billy Batson mark Strong is going to
play the villain dr. sivana
oh that's cool and who's directing this
thing David David F Sandberg from I met
the director uh I was interviewing
people at San Diego for IMDB and he
[ __ ] threw this out there so casually
it was crazy he directed Annabel
creation so I was like his little
softball question I was like what you
working on next and he goes up Shazam
and I was like shut the [ __ ] up
are you [ __ ] serious I was like when
did that happen he's I got a photo for a
little while but this is the first place
he talked about it and [ __ ] he just
threw it out there as if like you know
you know shows am like you did it once
right I'm my partner so yeah you seem
like a nice guy
I you know Zach ISM is a great choice
terms of character like he's got the
personality of a Shazam he's gonna
probably have to put on some [ __ ] a
lot of muscle yeah but he's a big dude
but he's not like a I don't think of him
as a muscular yeah he's a bit of a
whippet but I mean if Chris Pratt can
get into that shape you know that's what
he's looking at Zach Levi's going this
Mike Chris Pratt moment like I'm gonna
put on put on the beefsteak I'm gonna be
Shazam for sure I mean if and Hemsworth
the the greater Hunts worth is also not
naturally that big like if you see him
there I've seen him in movies where he's
just a guy and then you see him if
Thor's like oh we added 30 pounds of
muscle
to play Thor I saw [ __ ]
behind-the-scenes clip of Justice League
it was crazy but I've been in the movie
business 20 [ __ ] years I've never
seen this in my life but I guess it is
because I don't ever work with
characters that have muscles Jason Momoa
about to do a shot where you know he's
walking away from Bruce Wayne he's
walking into the water and [ __ ] and
right before they go my man is literally
pumping iron like not big weights but
big enough I guess that's because does
it make you look blood the Bloods
rushing to the muscles and it looks a
little flush and yeah is that what it is
so you'd see veins or it would be I
don't know [ __ ] about health so I didn't
know why one would I saw this I was like
why is he doing that and then I picked
PC together I was like oh he must look
more built but how could you look more
built than he already looks but it's I
guess you've gin in for and those dudes
also like I remember I had I will say
that I had dinner with one of the guys
on Teen Wolf I was the only one who ate
because the next day he had like a
shirtless scene he's that guy can I
can't eat anything saying why are
[ __ ] come to dinner she's watching me
in a burger it's like well because I
want to say hey but he couldn't eat for
24 hours before the scene so he can look
just emaciated is humanly possible guys
like us love that kind of [ __ ] because
it's the one thing that makes you go
well that's why I'm not saying cuz who
the [ __ ] wants to do that I want to eat
what I wanna eat yeah like I've got a
buddy who who was Hugh Jackman's
personal chef at one point and and he
would get contracted when he was making
Wolverine movie and it was alright I've
got to feed him every three hours I've
gotta wake him up to eat if he's got to
add this muscle and he's gotta work out
he's gotta eat a boil chicken he's got
to eat brown rice and like a hard-boiled
egg and then the next meal is like some
kind of protein shake and then the next
meal is it was just protein that all
sounds [ __ ] good man like you made me
hungry I'm like who is this chef tell me
about this but - after like waked dude
up at 3 o'clock in the morning to make
sure that he's eating enough especially
that guy yeah and like the worst food
you're like wake up he's like
those at one time I felt a little bad
for him is that he's got to be woken up
to eat he was [ __ ] built in the
leathery watch slogan like two weeks ago
and on my laptop like [ __ ] he looked
ripped and I know the younger version of
him like you know the duplicate or
whatever spoilers they they could young
them up in the face and [ __ ] but they
can't put more muscle on that was that
was all Jackman he was jacked man crazy
alright man says that all the news we
had us all the news writers fit to talk
about in Kansas City generally speaking
this is the point where we go to QA but
first ladies and gentlemen we got a
guest we don't get to do this so much on
fat man better and so when we get a
chance to do it we try to do it
welcome to the stage ladies and
gentlemen that [ __ ]
comic book legend and Batman adjacent to
artist give it up for David Finch David
come on up man why are you Finch is it
true you just won an Eisner this year
for that short story into the micro
they're never gonna hear me turn his mic
up to begin the number one thing I never
would have thought would happen to me
ever winning an Eisner cuz it's a
respectable award and that's not the
kind of work that I do so I'm forever
grateful to Tom this is so Tom King
wrote it you drew it if you haven't seen
it yet it was in what an annual a backup
story an annual yeah it's called good
boy and it is from the first panel of an
abused what you later I don't want to
spoil it but [ __ ] a lot of people
probably already read it if you don't
want to know the story cover yours count
of three I'm gonna say something it's
about the birth of ace the bat-hound and
it's a really [ __ ] touching story man
like it makes me well up I don't quite
roll them but my eyes get glassy where
I'm like oh my lord what was it like to
get that script
well when Tom said he wanted to do what
he said is it okay because it's about a
dog and I said sure
I can't draw animals so every panel that
I drew that dog was was referencing the
whole thing but it's hard to draw
animals if for me it's hard for some
artists so they're great at it and also
it's a German Shepherd so it's got like
the whole pattern anyway it's a more
complicated dog you're like why can't
this thing be a [ __ ] wiener dog man
yeah ace the wonder dog but you know it
was it was such a great story and he's
really good at you know getting all the
emotion across in the script and yeah I
knew it was gonna be worth drawing so it
was worth it it was worth the effort
it's a pretty damn powerful piece of
work what is it like when you win an
Eisner what do they do throw your party
calling it what is it is it a reward so
mother you're sitting that I wasn't
there so I was at home and Tom King was
there he accepted it and I he gave me a
call and said that I want to believe it
so I'm still amazed you know I was at
the eisenerz once and it is the most
boring award show you'll ever go to
really yeah man because imagine like
with all the graphics and sheer to be
colorful ads on a car graphics and
comic-book people are lovely many of
them are not funny and and none of them
are used to speaking in front of an
audience so so four hours of speeches
you're [ __ ] saying that in front of
our guest he wasn't he with all of his
criteria and I said we talked a little
bit earlier I said I'm not good at
talking in front of people so I don't
know how this is gonna go so first I
said don't worry I'll keep putting the
mic in your face all right Finch you're
Canadian
yeah where were you born Windsor Ontario
it's right it's actually south of
Detroit so yeah yeah it's like across
the bridge you're there yeah were you
were you one of those Canadian kids that
came over to America lottery or for
cheaper milk and gas or really like hey
man I'm patriotic [ __ ] that stupid land
over there until I want their money yeah
we went over a lot and bought stuff for
sure yeah what did you do what it was an
American like what was a Canadian thing
to do in a moment as a kid we used to go
to Gibraltar Trade Center and it's a big
huge
somebody just laughed they knew it
though the guy was there I got a hand
job there watch I got all my heavy metal
t-shirts there and you could get you get
the like butterfly knives one of those
you were that kid yeah and then you're a
kid with knives I had that one that was
it legal in Canada so I had to smuggle
that back my mother never knew it got
away with it
you crossed the border with a butterfly
knife yeah I was gonna go to modern-day
America a lot of things yeah things are
different
probably not all right so so you're
growing up a kid in Canada when do you
realize hey I can draw I used to draw
Snoopy I was a big peanuts fan when I
was young that's all I did and then I
kind of let it go and I'm a high school
dropout you know I
I barely drew in high school I drew
skulls a little bit you know and Eddie
from Iron Maiden that did him but I
didn't want to go back to school and my
sister read comics so I I got into it I
started reading it and I thought wow you
know maybe I could I could do it it was
it was really I don't know I just kind
of got lucky I backed into something
that in a minute I started doing I knew
was right and I loved it and you know
I've been doing it ever since but it was
what was the first gig what was the
first breakthrough Marc Silvestri was my
boss use Marvel ours for years and years
he did x-men and Wolverine and that's
the stuff that really got me into comics
and he he has a company called Top Cow
Productions a part of image and I worked
for him for seven years as one of the
original image founders yeah he's still
there and you know he taught me
everything I know and I got lucky I got
in at a time when there's a studio
system so there's a lot of young artists
and we're all kind of learned from each
other and you don't see that anymore
what are you talking about when was this
94 so a long time ago now it's true I
was talking I forget where we were
talking about but there's not any I mean
and maybe it's because I don't pay
attention to current comics as much but
it doesn't feel like there are as many
rocks to our names as when we were kids
for artists they just don't promote the
artists the way that they used to and
explain that I you know I don't know i
I'd like to say they're just not
promoting
enough maybe we're not doing as good a
job I don't know but there was a time
when you know it was all about the art
and the writing was really not as
important you know people just picked it
up for the art work more than anything
and I mean the stories were I think the
stories were great back then you know
but it was it was done much more seat of
your pants and there wasn't the planning
that goes into it now and you know when
the the early image guys came along in
the business todd mcfarlane just made
everything like larger than life and
hanging out of the panel and just
exciting and that's the stuff that got
me into comics and you know artists were
like rock stars and I think we kind of
lost some of that swagger and I'm for me
it's so important to get a writer story
across and I wanted you everything that
I could possibly do and you know for
some stories that means kind of keeping
it smaller and I'm willing to do that
but I think we still need you know some
of that bigness and some of the
creativity just see I think it's it's
tough to get into the business now and
be like just a really crazy different
artist you know in the way that you
could back then in it so yeah it is
worth noting that all of the image
founders were artists yeah all of them
it was that's what I think of as like
the that not in the 90s in that period
where spider-man the relaunch of
spider-man like all those different
covers of the books and it sold millions
of copies Jim Lee's x-men number one and
stuff that was when artists ruled like
they ruled back when Jack Kirby and and
Ditko and all those guys a whole history
of comics I think what changed it more
than anything really it's the internet
because the people on the Internet are
really much more story focused like
they're the hardcore the hardcore fans
and I think that they really influenced
editorial because editorial will go on
and read what you know these guys are
saying and I think that really steered
the business a lot and you know I think
it's also vertigo I think vertigo had
had a big part to play a big explain
what vertigo launched the books looked
like [ __ ] and I think to a certain
degree intentionally because they were
so enamored with look we got we got
grant we got Allen we got Neal we got
Garth like we got these guys and all
from the UK and they're all bringing
this punk rock aesthetic to comics and
was very much about the word and they
they went out of their way to brand the
writers as that as the sort of
visionaries or vertigo because the books
didn't look great every now and again
you'd find one that was like oh okay hey
that's pretty cool but all too often it
was bad paper it was not great art the
coloring was a little basic and and I
think that along with your right like
the rise the internet and people in love
with words like I think it just shifted
the alright so wait your first gig was a
top Cal yeah when did you how long were
you there before you segwayed over to
marvel and when you jump over to Marvel
is Silvestri like now you're going to
[ __ ] marvel man stay here at up Cal
or is he like oh you got to go and grow
I was there for seven years and when I
went I was young and I was kind of angry
and we went to a convention in Chicago
and all the editors at Top Cow all went
out for dinner and they get there at
dinner comped and the artists we got
stiffed and I was so angry and I knew
Joe Quesada you know we did a crossover
years before so I went right over to the
bar where he was sitting and I said hey
I want a job and really yeah
after seven years you're like they won't
buy my steak give me a book and Marvel
steak this is pretty much how I do
everything my whole life my pants I get
mad and then I'm yeah that's how it
happened really it was a rage move it
was a rage move but it worked I'm glad I
did so casada what year you talking
about the seven years of 2001 2001 yeah
so what are you what's he put you to
work on first I asked you to Wolverine
so I ended up doing a couple Wolverine
covers which was blast and then he had a
book called call of duty it was right
after 9/11 the whole you know the whole
thing and so I did a fireman theme book
so you know that was it was a challenge
for me you know especially I'm an image
artist through and through and I still
am you know I've learned a little bit
since then but I had to you know draw a
fire station and the truck and make
everything look you know proper and it
was it was a big learning curve for me
you know allowed to image the fire
truck or anything like wow yeah oh yeah
you can't do like oh I guess I I did
some speed lines I got him in there um
alright so what you work on after that
what was the big first big Marvel gig
we're a people like oh my god I know
your name and [ __ ] you start getting
lines at Comic Cons and one that well I
did x-men after that with Brian Bendis
who's you know Brian Bendis so that was
a big deal for me it was a huge deal and
I think when things really change though
and all of a sudden it was it was really
good times for me it was I did Avengers
Avengers disassembled where we killed
most of the old Avengers we got so much
flak on the internet for that I wanted
to quit I actually tried to quit I
couldn't take it why because people like
[ __ ] you well I don't I don't go on the
internet anymore I don't read any of the
stuff I learned my life so smart back
then I would go and I would actually I'd
go to message boards and type my name in
and search oh yeah yeah yeah I never do
that oh no you don't want to know what
they're saying
oh yeah well yeah so wait so it was
because how many issues did you get to
do it it was disassembled was five
issues five extra long issues and we
killed the vision we killed Hawkeye we
time killed him that we're all back now
you know but at the time we killed them
and people were very angry and then we
did New Avengers and we we had Wolverine
and while Captain America who else was
in there Iron Man there were a couple of
the characters were totally not Avengers
characters and spider-man there was
spider-man in there
so yeah fans were but it you know it
sold great and it was it was really good
for me and I quit after ten issues or so
and really I quit because I just I
couldn't handle the pressure you know it
was so successful I was doing great I
freaked out I quit
so in retrospect good or bad move it was
a terrible move it was yeah the dumbest
thing I've ever done
why tell me why Wow I'm you know I could
have written that for years I could be
you know synonymous with with Avengers
because I mean this is Bendis you know
at his prime on the Avengers he was
doing so well with it yeah who knows
what that could have done for me what
what did you do next though I did Moon
Knight next
and I'm huge I don't know if you guys
know Stephen Platt at all yeah anyway
I'd love his artwork he didn't moon I
had a couple issues and I wanted to do
that you know so there was a novelist
that turned into moon I pitch they
really liked and they asked Charlie
Houston Houston he's awesome yeah he's
great I've read a bunch of his books -
he's really good so yeah I ended up
doing moon night for you know as long as
I could and then one was the Marvel
break when did you have your I want a DC
steak [ __ ] you know what in a
way it was actually when I left Avengers
I wanted to go and do Batman because I
love Batman and the main reason I did
moon night is because he's so much like
Batman and I just wanted it to be Batman
and now actually I'd love moon night so
don't be wrong I love moon night but the
internet gonna come after you again I
know what you say about Maru night but I
finished one night I did another yeah I
was there for a little longer and my
contract was up and I just had the I if
I don't do it now it might never happen
so and I was so comfortable at Marvel I
mean they were so good to me they're
they're they're a great company so I I
could have just stayed forever but I
needed to go for it what happens in a
move do you make the approach to DC or
they approach you I approach them you
know I had talked to Dan DiDio as a
publisher at DC and he'd called before
so I'd talked to him but when I was
ready at I approached them when and so
it's scary to do that because if you
approach them then they could be like
well yeah they're like won't pay two
bucks clearly you need us so yeah but
they weren't they were good so when you
go to DC was the first thing that put
you in I did well I did the return of
Batman Batman the return anyway Grant
Morrison had killed Batman and they had
this whole story and then he was lost in
time the whole thing and they finally
brought him back and that was the first
book that I did Batman the return with
Grant Morrison the only time I ever got
to work with him so that was nice was it
like translating a Grant Morrison script
it was it it was I mean he's a great
writer and he knows what he's doing but
there were a few times where it was a
little bit tough and he doesn't
communicate you know so I had to kind of
guess and does you write in an accent
no he doesn't that's that's good at
least yeah so wait so you would read
something be like I don't know what to
do and you couldn't reach him so you're
like I'll just do this and so then I
would talk to the editor and the editor
wouldn't really know either so that I
said well I'm just gonna I'm gonna do ya
whatever and they said fine and you know
he seemed happy with it so it worked
well he said he was happy maybe he hated
it I don't know you're filled with a lot
of [ __ ] self-doubt Dave that's what
I'm getting out of this whole thing man
yeah trust me you're doing great all
right
all right so then what was the big DC
moment for you where you're like I'm
here I'm ensconced um well from there I
did Batman The Dark Knight which I wrote
to and I will never do again it was a
mistake he'd never written a comic
before I had a couple of little thing
but it's tough especially on a monthly
deadline by issue three yeah I was
figuring out what I was like I was
writing it so I could draw the next page
you know it was a design
like just say is that the order you did
it in so you took it seriously we're
like all right I'll write a script first
and then I will adapt my script image
wise I would imagine somebody who could
draw would just like well I'm gonna skip
the writing process I'm just gonna draw
a bunch of boxes or a bunch of images
and then I'll figure out the dialogue
like Martha stop well that's kind of
what ended up happening and you know if
I was Stan Lee and Jack Kirby would have
been great yeah it didn't it was it was
a bit of a train wreck and then I ended
up working with Greg Hurwitz who's
another great writer on that book for
quite a while that was that was good and
then I got to work with Geoff Johns you
know on we did forever evil which was a
big crossover with you know all the all
the DC forget to play with all the
characters that was great it was the
most fun I mean obviously you wanted to
go for Batman but who was the character
at DC they were like oh I had no idea I
would enjoy drawing this person or this
character as much I would say the one I
didn't realize I would draw I would
enjoy so much would be bizarro you know
and I knew that I'd enjoy him because
he's a I liked drawing the big dark
muscular kind of characters but he just
had so much heart the way he was written
I thought he was great and there was a
Lex Luthor who I liked because he was
bald
really
you're like I could draw that yeah yeah
I got all the references I need you know
it's like the Rockwell moment where
you're in the mirror painting is right
yeah
the comic a life of a comic-book
professional a lot of us I think dream
about that who love comic books over the
years I got to play in that arena by
writing and stuff like that but how much
of it is oh my god I draw for a living
and how much of it is like oh [ __ ] I got
a draw today
Wow yeah it's it's a tough way to ask
like how well how when does someone you
take your passion yeah and you make a
career of it there's a danger of losing
the love for just like I can create
something from nothing is somebody's
breathing down your neck then like you
better do it right now because we need
those pages and stuff so is there how
does one find balance between passion
for the work and just having to do the
work in a timely fashion oh wow you know
I don't think anybody's ever asked it
quite like that before it's really it's
a good question because I do panels like
this or whatever and I say I I draw
pictures for a living and I work in my
pajamas half the time like you can't
beat that it's it's great but really
that's me being grateful the truth is a
lot of it yeah it's very painful and you
know sometimes I just don't want to draw
there are times I don't want to draw
like a big superhero standing on a
building which is crazy you know and
then there are the days when I'm drawing
like a boardroom scene or whatever and
yeah it can be a little tough and it can
be tough to be grateful I think with
whatever whatever you're doing but I try
and learn all the time as much as I can
and I think that really keeps me engaged
you know if I just try and keep growing
and I really do love drawing I really do
so yeah what's your what's your favorite
part of the process
I mean is it thumbnails as it pencils is
it see the inks come in is it having the
book done like weird where do you get
the most joy my favorite part is when
the page is already laid out all the
shadows that are in and I'm just putting
all the detail on and then I'm kind of
just watching TV and I I really I enjoy
just losing myself in detail I can do it
for
hours and hours and I'm not having to
think the toughest part for me is is the
morning when I'm really trying to make
everything work on the page and and plan
and that's it's much harder I enjoy it
but I also hate it the if you had to
pick one character there like you only
get one to do for the rest of your life
and stuff who would you go down drawn
Batman because it's okay I'm gonna say
Batman because I love Batman died you
know I love all the villains it's great
and you know also I could do it forever
because people keep eyeing it but if it
were know if sales were not an option I
could just do it I would do Lobo I would
do Simon Bisley but I would want to be
Simon Bisley in do Lobo that's your
dream like that's who you are secretly
at heart and world sees David French but
you're like inside I'm Simon Bisley
doing oboe that's what I wanted you wow
that's the dream book what can I say
once you just go ask him I'm sure
they'll be like go ahead and they said
no yeah because you know they give you a
contract and then they expect you to
provide value and they don't think Lobos
got that kind of value no and I have not
been able to convince him because my
problem is that I it's my favorite kind
of comics are just like the over-the-top
muscles crazy you know you're an image
guy that's right it's what I like but
how do you tell an editor that and make
them go okay that sounds like a smart
move
have you thought about buying a mistake
I mean well hopefully after the podcast
they'll hear they'll hear I mean talk
wouldn't you guys like to see a Lobo
series by hell yeah
thank you play them that may be alright
so generally it's to hang out here what
we do what we like to do in this show is
open it up to Q&A and we'll keep david
around with us that way and maybe some
people have better questions than me and
Marc had and stuff but generally we're
gonna open it up for a few minutes talk
about whatever you guys want
talk about and then wrap and get out of
here so hands in the air
well oh there's a mic right there and
the or there's a mic right there just
pony up oh I guess you're right
telling people raise their hands as if
they didn't need to speak enormous okay
how are you man you're gonna be first go
first yeah ran into mark yesterday
Oswald but we got to get out of here to
go to my comic book release party at the
Mockingbird lounge and that's cool we'll
do one two three four five that's good
right there
but I just have like - like statements
really I'm excited for the true north
moose jaws hopefully that's still in the
pie hopefully yes finding money for a
movie called moose jaw's which is Josh
made with a moose instead of a shark has
been surprisingly challenging go figure
yeah it was easier if I'm financing for
Jay and Silent Bob reboot I think once
that happens then muchas will be cleared
yeah I feel really good with like horror
like red-state tusks all those crazy
[ __ ] movies thank you and then mark
definitely needs to get on some
directing I have a four and a half year
plan so by the time I hit the the
mid-century mark I I've declared that I
will have directed written and directed
a feature film so the balance of this
year oh thank you guys it's really we
yeah right on yeah so the the balance of
this year we'll be writing the script
for that thing and then I will spend the
balance of the years trying to find
somebody to pay for it but yes thank you
so keep word yeah guys you guys are
great thank you my friend hey guys it's
a hell of a Jersey my friend I'd you
signed it earlier and I'd thank you so
much but my question is for you Kevin on
fat man on Batman one of the earlier
ones with Paul Dini you guys were just
spitballing about Bruce Wayne's Jesus
years and I just remember listening in
my car and just pumping my fist like yes
and then like literally a week later
Gotham gets announced is that a crazy
coincidence or I think if I remember the
timeline correctly like
there's no way that they like could have
I think they were in motion when we had
our podcast I don't think it was like
somebody heard our podcast and I look
[ __ ] that's a good idea and pitch to
show that being said I do think that
some of the ideas trickled down because
the original version of Gotham that they
announced was very different than the
version that they're doing now and you
know could our version or the version we
mused about on the podcasts like oh man
you could show all the young versions of
all these characters now they interact
at Bruce Wayne mobile and that's kind of
what they wound up doing but nobody's
ever called us and said hey we we stole
your idea thank you and hung up and you
know to be fair it's like these aren't
they me and Paul were talking about
somebody else's characters anyway you
know how much of it can one claim to be
one's own if there was no Batman we'd
never have had that conversation indeed
there would be no podcast so at that
point it felt like you know number one
legal I wouldn't legally I wouldn't give
a [ __ ] it wasn't like I want my cut or
anything [ __ ] now but you know even if
they heard a podcast like whoo that's a
good idea incorporated and stuff that's
cool as long as the show got better or
somebody liked the show or whatever but
it'd be nice if like years from now and
the show was all finished somebody was
like yeah we totally stole your ideas
all right thanks thanks man hello hey
what's up how are you good now David
rules you're here and your low bow would
destroy I'd love to see that but my
inquiry is for a mark it's more like a
vocation question you kind of joke
around now that you're a focused
creative writer versus what you were
doing in the past you make the joke
about being unemployed I'm stoked about
your Stephen King show but in the
position you're in I know you have work
like laid out but in those open spaces
like do you like pass out a resume or
just kind of as a word-of-mouth are you
trying to find new gigs or how's that
function Oh a great question
yeah I mean the the the life of a TV
writer is ultimately a freelance life
you know you get contracted for certain
amount of time it's usually numbered in
weeks
and in the time that you're not actively
engaged the job is to a keep writing you
know like every every job should be get
the new job and every time you're
looking for the new job you have to have
a new thing to show so whatever I showed
to get the Castlerock job won't work to
get the next job because the way it
works is like everybody's seen it like
yeah that was great we liked it a year
ago what what do you have for me lately
and so it's it's writing it's it's
getting better like you're always
learning the the last script you wrote
should never be the best script you can
write you'll learn something as you go
you'll learn you'll get to get better at
it through iteration through practice
there's a lot of meetings in which they
give you bottled water and so there's a
lot of bladder challenging conversations
so bad somebody tell Oprah that it's
cool if I leave and go get a go to the
restroom and it's networking and not
like this shitty kind of networking but
Lee if you do it for a stretch and if
you're living in LA you'll meet other
people who do the same thing that you do
you'll find the community of writers
especially community of nerd writers and
just going out like being in the world
like getting yourself in contact with
other people to do that thing that you
like to do and through that people will
start to tell you like hey man I hear
they're looking for somebody on this or
hey I think there's there's an
opportunity on that it's it's engaging
with that world as much as you can
without being a dick about it
but it's also doing the work you know
like it's if if you're a writer you're
writing and writing doesn't always mean
sitting in a computer it doesn't always
mean typing something out it means being
in the world it means taking in new
experiences and means thinking about a
thing that you've been thinking about
for years and cracking it in your head
it means it means actively wanting to be
better at the thing you do and so for
the time that I'm not presently engaged
when I'm gainfully unemployed that is
kind of what I'm doing in one last thing
- what you said do you feel that even
with the power of the internet that
locations such as Los Angeles where
you're located that plays into it like
you think that that is definitely a big
piece of it
it it I think if you want to do TV it
does I think if you want it to be a
feature screenwriter if you wanted to be
a novelist if you want to write comic
books you can live anywhere but if you
want to be in TV you gotta be there to
do the meetings you got to be there and
it happened so fast you know like the
the first job I got I was flying back
and forth from from New Jersey to LA and
I went on a meeting and it went pretty
well and I flew home and I get a call
saying hey so they want you great that's
awesome was what I've been waiting for
Monday so I had to move cross-country in
a weekend because you can't say no you
can't say can you give me two weeks you
can't say guys I'm sorry but my kids are
in school and I just you have to be
there and life gets so much easier if
you can respond quickly because
Hollywood is very hurry up and wait and
when it's ready it wants it and once it
wants it and you have to be ready to go
so I would just say if TV is really what
you want then LA is where you need to be
bad thank you guys so much for coming
here for sure hey how's it going how are
ya I just had one quick questions yeah
signing earlier and I've had this
Sharpie question sure I could sign it
wire chitchat oh you bought a sharpie -
oh you're genius you did not bring a
Sharpie you're not uh he's got you he
has a sharpie now he's the genius
done and done anybody or just tagging
well I mean to anybody or just tagging
just write my name on it I'll stay right
there I'll be done in a second look it's
finished thank you bang we probably did
that in the wrong order but whatever and
now for the question
all right well since you were mentioning
an earlier since the 10th anniversary of
Zack & Miri is going to come you coming
up next year is it really yeah 2008 to
2018 my god wondering if there was any
plan to do a special edition or anything
with like commentary track or anything I
nobody's asked or anything like that but
we still owe a commentary track on the
movie when the movie when we were doing
you know the DVD release and when I'm
putting together the home video release
we were all depressed about how the
movie was doing or how it didn't do well
so I didn't want to do a commentary
track because it would have been one of
those sad commentary tracks like I
remember listening to the commentary
track for josie and the pussycats like i
like Josie the Pussycats I actually paid
to see in the theater but the movie
didn't do that well and stuff still did
better than most of my ship regardless
when it when they recorded their
commentary track I guess it was the
Monday after their opening so generally
when you record a commentary track
that's why they try to have them do it
like in production while productions
going on because it avoids moments like
this generally you know you're there's
either the movies come out or it's about
to come out so you don't know it's fate
to do it on the Monday after the opening
and then your opening is soft the
conversation isn't about like wow when
we did this it was fun it's like yeah we
all did this but what was the point so
that's that the zack and miri commentary
track definitely would have been a lot
of that but you know ten years on I
think that would be an ideal podcast I
think that would be I if I could get
Seth to come over and it shouldn't be
too [ __ ] difficult to come over and
we can watch the movie and do a podcast
uh what I would love to put up as a clip
that he did years ago him and Evan like
he was being interviewed for the DVD and
we couldn't include it on the DVD cuz it
was critical the people to put the movie
out but he did a sketch about like you
know the history of the movie that was
really really funny I would love to put
that out one day but yeah the commentary
tracks the easier one I'm gonna
definitely work on that for next year I
didn't realize it was ten years already
[ __ ] boy I haven't really gone anywhere
everyone in that movie did real well
except me I'm still treading water and
shits that's the director electic banks
is a director [ __ ] what am i doing with
my life but yeah we'll do a commentary
track at least me and him that'd be fun
alright thank you thank you you get to
end the QA man yes I do
I'm horrible with names so David David I
saw there was David I just can't
remember um
two cousins okay did you ever walk on
spider-man comics
I think yet oh thanks
I did a spider-man short story one time
and I did spider-man in New Avengers and
a crossover so yeah a little bit Marvel
comic to walk on sorry well with your
favorite Marvel comment to walk on
ultimatum which was a crossover that I
did with Jeff lobe because there was a
point in that book that we had the wasp
get eaten by the blob and I did a splash
page of that it was crazy so it just it
was so over the top it's something I
would never do now with kids you know
but at the time yeah there's a lot of
fun thank you thank you
we're good we're good
well thanks for the Q&A portion of the
show ladies and gentlemen it is now like
ten after nine and I think we're kind of
out of everything there is to talk about
this week y'all have a good time this
evening ladies can't thank you enough
for being here the beautiful thing about
a comic-con you see everyone's passion
worn right on their sleeves you know
generally in life you're supposed to
present the person you know who's the
professional or the grown-up and stuff
and your passions you kind of keep for
the weekends or whatever something like
this you get to see passion on full
display and hopefully you know as we
spoke with David's night you're heard
passion plays a big part in in finding
your future this guy I loved Ron guess
what he does for a living he [ __ ]
draws really well and he got to work on
every character he's ever wanted to work
on so dad although sagen except Lobo
except [ __ ] Lobo good point yeah
Marc's been listening to the show I
haven't but gives him something to shoot
for man otherwise he's like you know he
weeps like Alexander I've conquered it
all it said he's like wait Lobo so
there's something still to reach for if
you got a passion lean into it I
so I'm a kid from a young age and I
think most people tell their kids this
now when we were kids they told us like
you know when you grow up you go to
college and then after college you get a
job in blah blah now we tell our kids
like figure out what you love to do in
this life and then figure out how to get
paid for it that's the [ __ ] secret
man if you do that you get to live a
life like that draw on things that you
like or a life like that writing things
that you like or life like this
realizing that it's been 10 years since
[ __ ] zack and miri and you haven't
progressed one inch or anything like
that
find your passion if I can lean into it
that's kind of what the show is really
all about at the end of the day man so
for fat man I'm Batman I've been Kevin
Smith I've been mark by Norton
David Fincher tune in next time same fat
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith can I get
the city
[Applause]
[Music]
you